en estos vídeos hemos estado platicando
de un pequeño lavado de autos
competitivo y dibujamos su curva de
ingreso de producto marginal después
justificamos como esto realmente era una
curva de demanda lo que quiero hacer en
este vídeo es profundizar una idea que
solamente mencioné así díaz un poquito
en el primer vídeo que es que podemos
sumar todas estas curvas de demanda para
obtener la demanda de todo el mercado
laboral después le podemos decir de este
mercado de personas que se dedican a
lavar autos bueno voy a hacer el ejemplo
por aquí abajo y realmente es un cálculo
muy directo pero al principio puede ser
un poco anti intuitivo entonces déjame
poner por aquí algunos ejes voy a poner
algunos ejes ahí tenemos en el eje
vertical vamos a poner el precio que
están cobrando los lavadores de auto y
vamos a poner precio precio por hora
precio precio y en el eje horizontal
vamos a poner la cantidad de
trabajadores que se contratan entonces
les voy a ponerte de cantidad de
trabajadores por ahora digamos entonces
ahí tenemos los ejes horizontales bueno
entonces pensemos en la curva d
banda de trabajadores de dos empresas
distintas aquí esté aquí este y vamos a
pensar en la compañía de lavados para
compañía compañía y ahorita vamos con la
compañía a quién va a poner que es la
compañía ve compañía ve y déjame poner
que aquí las personas que están cobrando
50 pesos por hora aquí vienen acá 150 y
aquí es cuánto está dispuesto a
contratar la compañía que puede ser
cinco trabajadores o diez o quince bueno
pensemos que la compañía a por así por
un precio de 150 por hora no está
dispuesta a contratar a nadie va
entonces o de 100 si vamos a pensarlo
mejor consciente porque ahorita va a ser
más interesante poner acá 150 bueno
entonces a 100 pesos por hora no va a
contratar a nadie pero si el trabajo es
gratuito entonces la compañía va a
contratar a 10 personas más empleados ya
no le convienen por alguna razón
entonces eso de acá son dos puntos en
nuestra curva de demanda y ahorita para
que las cosas sigan siendo simples vamos
a pensar que nuestra curva de demanda es
lineal de esta forma otro punto en
nuestra curva de demanda sería este de
acá en el cual por 50 pesos las personas
están dispuestas bueno esta compañía
está después
a contratar 5 personas por hora
muy bien esa es la compañía y esta es su
curva de demanda ahora pasemos aquí a la
compañía ve de modo similar aquí tenemos
50 pesos 100 150 y supongamos que una
vez más la compañía ve que bueno ahora
por 150 no está dispuesta a contratar a
nadie quién es aquí a nadie pero luego
si el labor es gratuito entonces está
dispuesta a contratar a 12 personas
voy a poner que por aquí son 5 10
entonces más o menos por aquí serían 12
si déjame marcar por aquí el 12 más o
menos algo así entonces si trabaja es
gratuito contratan a 12 ok - se vieron
un poco más vivos que éstos verdad están
contratando más pero de hecho también
están contratando a personas por por una
menor cantidad va bueno entonces la
curva de demanda de esta compañía ve se
vería algo de este estilo
algo más o menos así entonces vamos a
poner algunos puntos más para que sea
ilustrativo entonces vamos a fijarnos en
en este punto de acá
cuando la gente cobra 100 pesos cuando
cobra 100 pesos más o menos bueno de
hecho puedes hacer las cuentas como esto
es un tercio de 150 aquí es una
diferencia de 50 aquí vamos a tener un
tercio de 12 entonces aquí contrata a
cuatro personas y cuando el precio es de
50 aquí contrata a 8 personas muy bien
entonces aquí vas a ver por qué te digo
esto de que es más o menos anti
intuitivo sumar estas dos curvas de
demanda y la cosa es que vamos a sumar
las horizontalmente si así
horizontalmente a qué me refiero con
esto a que por cada precio fijo nos
vamos a fijar en la suma de las
cantidades de personas que contratan y
que contrataba entonces déjame marcar
aquí de nuevo y 50 marcar aquí el 100
y marcar aquí el 150 observa como lo
estoy alineando para que quede más claro
y aquí voy a marcar que contratan a 5 10
15 o 20 bueno a lo mejor pueden ser más
verdad veintitantos entonces como como
tendríamos que sumar vamos a sumar punto
a punto pero en precios entonces qué
sucede digamos con un precio de 150 pues
nadie está contratando nadie contrata
entonces aquí tenemos este punto de acá
ahora qué sucede con el precio de 100
pues al no contratar a nadie pero ve
contrata a cuatro personas entonces
tendríamos el punto 400 aquí este de
aquí ahora podemos simplemente completar
esto como una línea pues no porque
estamos sumando dos líneas y eso no
necesariamente nos va a dar una línea
bueno a veces y a veces no pero aquí en
este caso este pues no por qué porque
como que se corta así entonces lo que
tenemos que hacer ahora es ver qué
sucede con el precio de 50 aquí le está
compañía contrata 5 esta compañía
contratada 8 entonces en total contratan
a 13 personas más o menos un punto de
acá y finalmente cuando cuando el labor
es gratuito cuando no se paga nada ésta
contrata 10 y ésta contrata 12 entonces
quedaría más o menos por aquí por 22
ahora si estos tres puntos y están en
una línea y estos dos también entonces
se vería algo de este estilo estos dos
los unimos así
y estos son los unimos aquí realidad de
este punto medio ya haber quedado un
poco más este más más arriba así
entonces bueno por esto digo que es más
o menos anti intuitivo porque ahorita
estamos sumando horizontalmente y con
eso obtenemos la demanda total déjame
ponerle que aquí es del mercado de todo
el mercado laboral de los grabadores de
auto entonces con esto tenemos este la
demanda total de trabajadores a cierto
nivel de precios y es anti intuitivo
porque en álgebra usualmente sumamos al
revés sumamos verticalmente y usualmente
cuando sumamos funciones sumamos así va
bueno entonces esto de esto se trata de
sumar curvas de demanda y espero que
este vídeo te haya sido de utilidad